des citoyens court se réfugier dans une
station de métro les sifflets des
policiers et les sirènes d'alerté raids
aériens retentissent aux quatre coins de
taipei
automobilistes et motocyclistes doivent
se garer
dans ce sous sol aménagé pour la
diffusion en direct à la télé locale de
l'exercice des responsables expliquent à
des figurants comment se protéger les
citoyens de taipei prennent cet exercice
militaire très au sérieux la population
a répondu à l'appel
gardez cette artère qui est normalement
bond est congestionné cdr
pendant trente minutes lundi tp s'est
transformée en ville fantôme des
exercices d'évacuation en cas d'attaqué
aérienne ont lieu dans les villes
taïwanaise toute la semaine
c'est une bonne façon de se préparer au
pire selon cette femme qui restait terré
dans son magasin de chaussures pendant
l'exercice et langues et
résume cet homme lui croit que davantage
de citoyens devraient avoir accès aux
abri antibombes du gouvernement lors de
l'exercice afin de mieux se préparer
pendant ce temps l'armée taïwanaise
donne le coup d'envoi à sa semaine
d'exercices militaires
défense antiaérienne et entraînement de
réservistes taiwan veut lancer le
message à son voisin chinois que lille
est prête à faire face à une possible
invasion qu'elle a retenu une leçon de
la guerre
unity
la chine pour sa barre multiplie ses
incursions dans l'espace aérien
taïwanais et durci le ton contre les
états unis pour empêcher la visite à
taipei de la présidente de la chambre
des représentants nancy pelosi tient du
fan day nous réagirons vivement si une
telle visite a lieu prévient-il les
etats unis devraient en subir les
conséquences
alors risque réel de guerre et
d'invasions imminente probablement pas
selon cette spécialiste difficultés que
la russie a rencontré en ukraine même si
elles s'imposent aux basses et bien à
démontrer à pékin que vraiment sans
envahir taiwan contrôle et taiwan tenir
taiwan et bien c'est une opération qui
serait extrêmement difficile
taiwan multiplient malgré tout les
exercices de préparation de tout genre
ces dernières semaines de nombreux
citoyens inquiets apeurés se préparent
aussi au pire ici philippe leblanc radio
canada taipei